bioinformatics for infectious diseases
will be the topic of today's session
but before we actually start the session
i wanted to talk a little bit about
what we do in the omixlogic training in
general
and that will kind of give the context
for what we will be talking about today
so omix logic is essentially a program
that combines the logic of data science
in application to biological data with a
community that
is passionate about developing research
projects using bioinformatics tools
and applications of bioinformatics to a
variety of topics
and so we believe that the
the students clinicians faculty of all
backgrounds
need to be enabled with the skills and
the tools that are needed to process
large data sets so as we go through the
first several steps i want to introduce
you to some of these resources that make
this possible
and after we go through this first part
i
will be talking about the topics of the
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program
and as we will try a few things
with the hands-on exercises that we'll
do today so hopefully you can also
uh start by registering on the platform
that we will use
before we start this session okay
so before we begin uh let me just go
through some of the
resources that we will be using today
the first one
is learn omixlogic.com now some of you
might already be registered on this
portal so if you already are registered
please make sure that you're logged in
and you have your password ready because
we're going to be doing a few examples
on our big data analysis platform to
kind of give you a sense of what kind of
exercise we'll be doing is to go right
here to the login
and then you can either log in with your
email
and password or create an account or you
can also use one of the
social media portals platforms here to
create an account so once you're logged
in you will see
a number of resources and we will be
talking about some of these resources
today
so to gain free access to a lot of these
resources all you need is the
registration on the portal
so some of these resources are going to
be useful in the program
as well as in today's session and after
today's session you can explore them a
little bit more
so some of the things that we'll talk
about in these resources
are the terminology that we'll be using
today the logic of analysis building
different pipelines for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of data
what are some of the technical skills
that you will be needing
knowing how to visualize data and
explore that data using r and python
and then also you will see how you can
evaluate your understanding of some of
the topics that we will be covering
by covering project applications of
bioinformatics
methods or quizzes for self-evaluating
now importantly we think that these
elements
really come complete a successful
journey for anyone coming from a very
introductory background so you might not
know
anything about bioinformatics before
joining this program
or you might already be an engineer or a
biologist
and the way that we view these
two parts of bioinformatics that biology
and the data
is that really they merge together as we
start speaking about some of the
applications of bioinformatics and the
only way to explore the applications of
bioinformatics
is to really focus on examples on
projects
and so what omixlogic portal does is it
offers
a variety of specialization tracks such
as
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture
for anyone who's interested in these
topics to appreciate the role
data science and bioinformatics can help
in the research areas and
also in translational research how to
develop new applications for medical
purposes pharmaceutical
agriculture and others and so
what the portal offers is two separate
tracks on biology on
data science using curriculum that was
evaluated by experts in these fields
and providing resources that could be
leveraged for an effective program
now besides the program that we are
using
that we are discussing today we have
several other
tracks that you can benefit from so you
can look at
introduction to bioinformatics to kind
of get started and understand what it's
all about
you can learn specifically about genomic
data analysis and application to
infectious diseases oncology or
neuroscience
transcriptomic data analysis for
immunology studies or for
understanding of gene expression in
complex diseases
metagenomic analysis of data from the
microbiome
where you sample environmental samples
and analyze their composition
epigenomics the regulation of
non-genomic
variation in response to different
diseases or environmental changes
as well as a training program on data
science
and that program is specifically for
those that would like to get
practical hands-on skills for data
visualization data wrangling
statistical analysis as well as machine
learning
and artificial intelligence and so those
programs will be
offered and at the end of today's
session we will hear from
dr mohit mizunder who will describe what
are some of the upcoming
programs that we have that we have on a
rolling basis
together these provide a complete
road map for data science in application
to biological
data or biomedical research and so you
can see how
finding data sets identifying uh
patterns through visualization
performing statistical analysis and
understanding the research methods that
you might read about or you might be
familiar with as well as gaining
biological insights into these data sets
providing with
evidence-based or data-driven hypotheses
so that's really the focus of this
portal
and hopefully by now all of you
have had a chance to create an account
now
who benefits from such training we have
a few examples here as you can see this
could include
faculty researchers students we serve a
community of uh participants from
all around the world including india
africa
the us and europe and so we are
excited to kind of continue and develop
and build this community that comes from
very diverse backgrounds but with a
common interest of
application of bioinformatics to a
variety of biomedical
and biological challenges so
to enhance this experience we also
welcome you to join
our group on linkedin we have a group of
professionals
that offer opportunities for internship
and jobs career building so if you're
interested in the application of
bioinformatics to
a variety of biomedical challenges and
you're looking for a job or you're
looking for an
internship we welcome you to join this
community of
experts and students alike so that you
can learn about
different training programs internships
jobs and understand how experts
have uh gotten to where they are today
so
to join this linkedin group if
you could share the link again for the
linkedin group
and we also have a group on facebook
also for those of you that use facebook
you can also join that
social media platform where we
do the same we post insightful resources
as well as opportunities for internships
mentorship job applications and
our participants that complete our
training are able to share
some of their projects as a result of
the research fellowship that they
conduct with our company